for Logan Paul my only thing was again
and this is me coming from a legit
Sports background there's no suing and
fighting your payback no matter how
nasty it gets you have a chance to
legally beat the crap out of this guy
and not go to jail that's the payoff
Logan Paul did that Logan Paul
embarrassed Dylan danis job well done
mission accomplished Logan You've Won
dude in life several times over your
fiance is beautiful your brother's
crushing it you live in Costa Rica where
whatever the hell he is Puerto Rico
Puerto Rico same thing you've won you've
proven to us you can beat the crap out
of Dylan danis you've done it dude this
law suit drop it it's over you did it
dude you did it you embarrassed Dylan
danis you did it bud that's it that's
where this thing stops cuz what we don't
want to have happen the next time you
fight slogan Paul you're not going to
get the same Impressions you're not
going to get the same buildup cuz
they're going go I got to be careful man
I'm GNA get sued that's what we don't
want